okay let's try our caller from the 6:07
area code
who's calling today from 6:07 hey David
yes I can you're coming in so loud just
pull the phone a little bit away from
your mouth and then I think we'll be
able to hear you much better doctor
how's that my phone it's marginally
better but I would keep going what's
going on uh not much I asked you a two
questions if you can first one not
started make it short and sweet only
recently been becoming politically
literate to the life so you know you and
Kyle kolinsky back in 2016 come Hilary
all that mm-hmm
so these days you try to research
hormone walls you get is his you know
his recent briefings and press
conferences so I was curious if even if
I could get your perspective on why he
seems to be so hated I'm from upstate
New York I wonder if it's a second
Amendment thing or if there's more that
I hadn't research obviously I'm still I
have another idea why why rural New York
upstate errs would hate Andrew Cuomo I
mean I know that on the Left there's a
contingent that doesn't like him because
he's not really that progressive I mean
he's a pretty you know he's a pretty
centrist Democrat and on fiscal issues
in the state of New York year he doesn't
have any particularly progressive record
so I think that I I couldn't tell you
about the gun people in upstate New York
but overall the left the left left isn't
thrilled with him because they feel that
the good press he's getting around
handling of coronavirus ignores the fact
that he has a very very centrist
moderate fiscal record in the state of
New York yeah absolutely that makes
sense I was also curious if you could
also state your perspective on where you
think Andrew gangs future what might
whole to him I liked him initially you
know I don't get the bag that's
hilarious but he does have some other
policies I like and I do like the fact
that he's he's not a politician but now
I feel like he's you know he's thinking
about running for for mayor I believe
and he's working for CNN and all that so
I was curious if you think that's gonna
gonna benefit him or maybe he should
maybe should get that experience or if
he should continue trying to be I have
absolutely no advice whatsoever for
Andrew yeah I mean listen on the
popularity and following that he built
he probably would be able to find a
congressional seat to run for and have a
really good shot
he could probably have a shot you know
maybe someday at a Senate seat might
require him you know maybe maybe to move
to a different state potentially but
he's built a following that would allow
him to raise money and likely do very
well for a number of different positions
but I have no advice and I have not
heard anything about his aspiration so I
wouldn't be able to say I'm gonna let
you go because that that that you're
just so right on your phone that it's
crinkling and crunching we're gonna take
a quick break if you were holding don't
hang up because I will be going right
back to the phone's momentarily my
friends